laisse moi tranquille tout ce que j'ai
dit c'est qu'on pourrait laisser tomber
la rando je parlais pas de nom en
général je parlais de la rando envie de
faire en sorte que nos coûts plagnard
est notre couple va bien c'est quoi ça
les cloches d'une église schumi gadoue
bienvenue dans notre eau vive nos zamis
est probablement un truc qui font près
tout est ce qu'on peut y aller
maintenant mois déjà c'est comme si vous
pouvez pas partir c'est de la magie on
est dans une réalité de comédie musicale
sur saône avant tout le monde
[Musique]
exit construit prisonniers jusqu'à ce
qu'on trouve le vrai amour est ce que tu
crois que ce qu'on vit de ses véritables
qu'est-ce que je me bats tous
considèrent comme le grand amour on n'en
sait rien laquelle deux voies envie de
traverser le pont avec moi envie de
tenter le coup avec d'autres personnes
de vous forcer les deux vous êtes en
versant tu comparer à vous je suis des
albanophones allons vite retrouver vos
chaussures
ça
[Applaudissements]
mais quand c'est là pour toujours vous
allez laisser tomber comme ça on est
malin on arrive bien à sortir d'ikea
trouvera un moyen
mesdames vous avoir un glissement
[Musique]
dans une comédie musicale n'y a pas de
morts dans les comédies musicales sauf
oklahoma et carousel et south pacific
airways a history romo citer toutes les
comédies musicales